[موسيقى]
انتهت قبل قليل في الرياض القمه العربيه
الطارئه وقرر بيانها الختامي بالاجماع
اعطاء اسرائيل مهله 48 ساعه تبدا من منتصف
هذه الليله للانسحاب من المسجد الاقصى
المبارك واخلاء شرقي مدينه القدس بالكامل
كما قرر زعماء الامه ما يلي اولا الغاء
معاهدات السلام المنفرده مع اسرائيل
والعوده الى مبدا الاجماع العربي ثانيا
انهاء كل الخلافات العربيه العربيه فورا
وفتح جميع المعابر المغلقه مع غزه وقطر
ثالثا وقف النار في سوريا والعراق واليمن
وليبيا وفتح باب التطوع للجهات ضد اسرائيل
رابعا وقف تصدير النفط والغاز الى اسرائيل
والدول الداعمه لها حتى اشعار اخر خامسا
اعلان الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله مسرح
عمليات مفتوحه للمقاومه بقياده الرفيق ابو
مازن سادسا تشكيل قوات تحرير القدس من نخب
الجيوش العربيه بقياده الفريق السيسي
استعدادا لخوض حرب التحرير في حال عدم
الانسحاب رائيلي سابعا واخيرا تكليف دوله
الامارات باختراق ما امكن من الحسابات
الالكترونيه
الاسرائيليه هذا هو المرتجى العربي اما
واقع الحال فبعد
العناوين داعيه سعودي يدعو لوقف قتال
اليهود واخر يحفز على الجهاد في
اليمن جرجاس في لغه الجسد مرتبك مرتكب
ومتاب
علي جمعه يعلن ان الرسول الكريم من برج
الحمل ويحمل
صفاته على شاشه مصريه الدوحه وضعت سحرا
داخل ستار
الكعبه مرحبا في لحظه واحده سقطنا جميعا
من المحيط الى الخليج لقد منعت اسرائيل
المسجد الاقصى يذكر فيه اسم الله فكان لها
ما ارادت واقفلت لثلاثه ايام وعط صلاه
الجمعه بعد عمليه نفذها ثلاثه مقاومين
مستقلين
واستقلالية البحرينيه الداخليه راح ينظر
على شعب الجبارين الفلسطينيين ويفتي
بالنيابه عن علماء الامه من سلف منهم ومن
خلف فيقول في تغريده غرابيه غريبه ان
الصلاه في المسجد الاقصى حق للمسلمين لا
يمس ولا يمنع كثر خيرك معالي الوزير اما
مساله قتل شرطه الاحتلال يتابع المفتي
المفوه والقانوني المحكم والوزير المعجزه
فتحكم المعاهدات وبالاخص اتفاقيه الجناب
الرابعه وقد غاب عن حشو راس الوزير ان
الجناب الرابعه خاصه بالمدنيين كما ان
المسجد الاقصى يقع تحت الاحتلال وان
مقاومه الاحتلال حق انساني كفلته الشرائع
الدوليه من ميثاق الامم المتحده الى
اتفاقيات مؤتمري لهاي لقد انسانا نبوغ
الوزير الخالد ثابته الزعيم الخالد ما اخذ
بالقوه لا يسترد بغير
عداك المنطق يا الوزير كما عداك العدل
عندما نعيت القاتل شيمون بيريز بعد موته
قبل شهور فوصفته برجل الحرب ورجل السلام
وما كان اريز يحارب الا بني جلدتك مغتصبا
مقدسات المسلمين والمسيحيين ولم يسالم من
سالمه فاستوطنها
واستوطنت له ارقد بسلام سيمون بيريز معالي
الاعجوبه بجرحك على رحي لبيريز اجبني هل
رقصت في عيد الانوار اليهودي قبل ثمانيه
شهور في العاصمه المنامه هل كنت بين
الراقصين على انشوده سيبنى الهيكل ان فعلت
فاننا لم نفقد في تلك الليله الا بضعه
ارطال من عصاره التطبيع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
المجاني
الحريه للشعب
البحريني يلتهي بقضايا داخليه احنا صناع
القرار في هذه البلد مش لا البحرين ولا
السعوديه ولا الامارات ولا الاردن ولا اي
بلد ثانيه احنا اللي بقرر وفقط احنا اللي
بقرر احنا ما بنتخ عن كرامتنا ما بنطلع من
اسرانا واقصانا وفلسطين بشكل عام في
التاريخ كله مين هو هذا مين هو عشان يحدد
مين احنا يعني ما بدناش نقول لك عيب نغلط
يعني بقول له يسلم على ثمك بدل ما تقف
معناا انت وشعبك زي ما قال الرئيس ياسر
عرفط الله يرحمه يشرب من بحر غزه لا يا
خالتي الداعيه السعودي احمد القرني غرد
خارج جميع الاسراب فدعا الى ترك المسجد
الاقصى لليهود ليش يا شيخ قال لانهم
الاقوى حاليا فهل هذا يعني يا مولانا انه
اذا اعتدى احد على المسجد الحرام بمكه
المكرمه حرام في شرعك قتاله اذا كان اقوى
منك في هذا الوقت شيخ سعودي اخر كان يحفز
قوات عسكريه سودانيه مرسله الى الحدود
السعوديه اليمنيه على القتال لاجل ان يخب
لكم الرباط والجهاد والقتال وتدافع عن
رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم هل اصبحت اسرائيل دوله سنيه تتساءل
المعارضه السعوديه مضاوي الرشيد لكن
سؤالها لم يفصل على اي مذهب الوهابي
السعودي القطري ام الصوفي الاماراتي
المصري تبدو كانها دوله سنيه لان تحالفها
مع السعوديه ومع الامارات دولتين مهمتين
ماليا ا قد تطور لدرجه انها اصبحت حليفه
لهم عندما تصير مجازر في العالم العربي
هناك اصوات سعوديه مدعومه من الحكومه تقول
والله الصهاينه لم يفعل فينا مثل ما فعل
اكس او واحد شخص اخر لماذا هذا كله خطاب
يعني يؤهل المجتمع على الاقل نفسيا لتقبل
اسرائيل كجزء من المنظومه العربيه
المنظومه العربيه الخليجيه وزير الدوله
السعودي ثامر السبهان غرد فقال في الماضي
نشتكي من عداوه اسرائيل والان اصبح اخوه
لنا اشد كرها وحربا علينا
منها ليش اسرائيل بتكره يا ثامر الله
يسامحك اصلا زوال اسرائيل ليس من مصلحه
العرب اسال مواطن سلمان الانصاري
[موسيقى]
من هو سلمان الانصاري اهو من الانصار
انصار من انصار
[موسيقى]
اسرائيل لكن محمد بن سلمان كسر بيمناه
حاجز العمر الزجاجي هو ليس فقط رئيس
الجاليه السعوديه في امريكا بل يقال انه
يعمل سرا في الانتاج السينمائي وقد اشتغل
على فيلم يوصم قطر بالارهاب لكنه اقفل
هاتفه
[موسيقى]
ومضى
لماذا كل هذا التحامل على دوله الامارات
العربيه المتحده العظمى فقط لان التحقيقات
الامريكيه اثبتت بحسب الصحيفه المرموقه
واشنطن بوست وتاكيد مؤسسات اعلاميه
امريكيه اخرى والكل بامريكا عم يحكي حتى
اصحاب البقالات ان ابو ظبي هي القرصان
الالكتروني الذي اخترق وكاله الانباء
القطريه شو يعني وهل الامارات هي الدوله
الوحيده التي تخرق مواقع الكترونيه ماذا
عن روسيا وما الذي يميز روسيا الاتحاديه
عن الامارات المتحده الجيش
[موسيقى]
الاحمر
وزير الدوله الاماراتي للشؤون الخارجيه
انور جرجاس وتحلو لنا تسميته بوزير
الوزراء لانه يفهم في كل شيء كان على موعد
مع الارهاب فرد من لندن على سؤال موفد
الجزيره الارهابيه عثمان اي فرح ما اكده
ان القصه التي نشرت الواشنطن بوست غير
صحيحه
مطلقا ليس لدي سبب يمكن ان نقول لك هذا هو
السبب الذي فشر الوضع في هذا الوقت
بالذات انوار انتبه في المره القادمه لا
تحك انفك اثناء الاجابه لان تفسير ذلك هو
انك تراوغ ولا تحك راسك ايضا فذلك يعني في
لغه الجسد انك مرتبك ومرتكب
ومرتا سيقولون عنك كاد المريب ان يقول
خذوني ما بقدر ارفع صوتي البرنامج متعاطف
معك انوار ضدي اللي اهبو بانك عميل
للصهاينه استغفر الله مستر قرقاش يا خاين
يا خاين يا عميل للصهاينه يا خاين يا عميل
الهينه وما شانكم به يا اخوانج هو يتحالف
بصدق ومحبه مع اسرائيل وليس عميلا لها يا
عملاء المجوس والروس والفلوس والفؤوس
بالرؤوس ثم هل تعتبرون مصطلح الصهاينه
شتيمه والله سوف يرفع عليكم جرجاش دعوه
يتهمك فيها بمعدات الساميه اي معاداه
اليهوديه كمجموعه عرقيه ودينيه واثن تماما
كما اتهم شبكه الجزيره برساله شكوى الى
الامم المتحده قناه الشارقه الاماراتيه
استحت من ذكر عباره معاداه الساميه اثناء
عرضها شكوى جرجاش بقدر ما هي رد مباشر
وضروري على تحريض الجزيره المستمر والخطير
على العداء والعنف
والتمييز وزير الوزراء دخل استوديو سكاي
نيوز البريطانيه فاعتقد انه في استوديو سم
نيوز الاماراتيه وسيحظى بالمساعده لكنه
فوجئ بانقضاء المحاور عليه ومحاصرته من
جميع المحاور فيما يبدو ان الامريكيين
تجسسوا على اجتماع حكومتكم هل هذا
صحيح انا لم اطلع على التقرير كله هناك
ادعاء ان الامريكيين تجسسوا على حكومتكم
وانت لم تقرا الموضوع بعد كان لدي لقاءات
كثيره اليوم يدعي من يدعي ان ابو ظبي
ايقظت الفتنه بين قطر والشقيقه الكبرى
السعوديه بينما هي مجرد مزحه كسرت رتابه
الصوره الجامعه بقمه الرياض تون شايفينهم
في الرياض ايش حلوهم مجتمعين مع بعض
يسولفون يضحكون ومصورين مع بعض
تعاون مستانس واشنطن ليس فقط تكشف
الاختراق الذي بنيت عليه الفتنه بل ينفي
التقرير السنوي لوزاره خارجيتها تهمه
الارهاب عن قطر ويشيد بتعاون الدوحه في
مجال مكافحه الارهاب فالى اين تذهب دول
الحصار هذا المساء بطل في مصاري ثمن تذاكر
سينما يضعان المليارات فيك يا
ترامب متفوقا على اعلى نجوم الرياضه والفن
اجرا في العالم ترامب يكسر اللائحه برقم
قياسي فلكي ويتقاضى لقاء رقصه العرضه 460
مليار دولار فقد اعترف ترامب انه اشترط
على السعوديه دفع مئات المليارات حتى
يشارك في قمه الرياض وقلت لهم يجب عليكم
ان تفعلوا ذلك والا فانني لن اقوم
بالزياره ولذلك صرفوا مئات المليارات من
الدولارات
[موسيقى]
ضحي خلفان عايش بغير دنيا فاتح التويتر
ومكيف وقد اقام قبل يومين مجلس عزاء بقري
واعلن في صوره وتعليق ابقار قطر تفس من
الحر الصوره ماخوذه من فيديو منشور في عام
2012 فهذه التعزيه لضاحي مع مفعول رجعي
بثت قناه الجزيره ما ظهر وكانه اشاره
تضامنيه من سيارات الاجره في لندن مع قطر
في مواجهه حصارها نشاهد احد اكاسي واقف
هنا لفت بلوكد ا ب قطر ارفعوا الحصار عن
قطر هذا هو الملصق يا جزيره هذه اعلانات
مدفوعه الاجر عيني يعني هذا الاسبوع عليها
عبارات تضامن مع قطر ربما الاسبوع المقبل
تستاجرها الامارات تكتب عليها قطر
ارهابيه اسهاما في نشر الاعتدال سوف نحاول
عرض فتاوى تصب في هذا الاطار وهذا الاسبوع
اخترنا لكم فتوى لمفتي الديار السعوديه
الشيخ عبد العزيز ال الشيخ يحذر فيها من
اللعبه الضاله المضله
الشطرنج البلاء القادم من بلاد الفرس لعبه
الشطرنج
محرمه وهي داخله في الميسر في عموم قوله
انما الخمر والميسر والانصاب والازلام رجس
من عمل الشيطان فاجتنبوه لعلكم تفلحون هي
مشغله للوقت ومنفق للمال وسبب للعداوه
والبغض المتعبين يدخلها الغني ويخرج
الفقير ويدخلها الفقير ويخرج الغني فهي
سبب للعداوه والتناحر فهي بلاء وقضاء وقت
في غير محله
والله ما بعرف بجوز نعرض هالفيديو علي
جمعه وصل على الابراج مش ابراج دبي الحمل
والتور والدلو والسطل وكلهم يبيح تداولها
من باب معرفه صفات الناس ويقول ان الرسول
عليه الصلاه والسلام من مواليد برج الحمل
ويحمل صفاته لا حول ولا قوه الا بالله
فسموه الحمل الحمل
ده اخره 21 20
ابريل ف 21 ابريل سيدنا النبي مولود في 20
ابريل فهو في برج
الحمل فلما تقرا الصفات بتاع برج الحمل
تلاقي صفات
سيدنا طب جايه منين من التتبع من
الاستقراء هذا القدر من المعرفه لا شيء
[موسيقى]
فيه
احيا الاتراك الذكرى السنويه الاولى لفرار
رئيسهم المخلوع رجب طيب اردوغان الى
المانيا وطلبه اللجوء اليها وفق تقويم
وتقييم قناه سما نيوز
الاماراتيه هناك عفوا هناك ايضا كلمه اخرى
يبدو انه تم تصويره
عبر الانترنت من قبل من كان معه من
اعلاميين ماذا
يقول الصوت غير واضح وزير الداخليه
العراقي قاسم الاعرجي الذي يعتقد ان
السعوديه هي التي قتلت سيدنا الحسين يزور
الرياض للمره الثانيه خلال شهر ويتوج
زيارته بلقاء ولي العهد الامير محمد بن
سلمان بهذا العمل الجم الذي اقدم عليه
حكام ال سعود هذه البرقيات والتيدا
ومحاوله تزويق حكم ال سعود بتاكيد سوف لا
يغطي على الجريمه النكراء التي
[موسيقى]
ارتكبوها نحن نعتقد ان ما يجري في سوريا
ليس هي قضيه شعب وانما وفق مخطط يقاد من
قبل امريكا
والسعوديه
[موسيقى]
احمد موسى زعلان من نيران القنوات الصديقه
ومعه حق يزعل امبارح بصراحه قناه
الحدث وارجو انهم يشوفوا اللي انا هعرضه
لانه لا يفرق بين الشهيد في مصر والشهيد
في اي دوله بما فيها المملكه العربيه
السعوديه قدام حضراتكم اهو الداخليه
السعوديه استشهاد جندي في القطيف باطلاق
على دوريه لحرس الحدود وتحتيها مقتل خمسه
من الشرطه المصريه انا بقول لهم عيب انا
بقول لهم عيب ايضا مواطن سعودي يحتج على
تغطيه قناه العربيه لاحداث المسجد الاقصى
قناه العربيه مصره على استخدام كلمه قتلى
لوصف شهداء فلسطين على يد الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ليه ما تدري ليه وانا مصدقهم
بدون ما حد يحلف انه ما يدري ليه اذا كانت
قناه العربيه تمثل صوت المواطن السعودي
وين المواطن السعودي اللي يشوفن شهداء
فلسطين على يد الاحتلال اسرائيلي قتلى مهم
شهداء مثل صوت المواطن السعودي باختصار
واس والاخباريه اللي تقول عن الشهيد شهيد
سواء كان من جنودنا البواس او من الشهداء
الفلسطينيين مع محمد الغيطي قطر تقوم بعمل
سحر في ستار الكعبه المحروسه في عمل على
الستاره شيخ صبري اهلا بيك اهلا وسهلا
محمد دلوقتي انت سمعت عن حكايه الاعمال
اللي بيشيلوها من ستاير الكعبه دي ايوه
الفيديو قدامي هوز عناه وبيقول لك ان قطر
هي اللي عاملاه وبيقول لك ان قطر هي اللي
عاملاه وبيقول لك ان قطر هي اللي
[موسيقى]
عاملاه قطر كانت هذا الاسبوع ليمونه فؤاد
الهاشم ودجاجه عبد الله الجنيد وسلحفاه
سلمان الدوسري القياده السياسيه او النظام
السياسي في قطر وليعذرني الاخوه في قطر
هذا التوصيف كانه دجاجه مقطوعه الراس كما
تفعل السلحفات حين تحس بالخطر وتكتفي
باغماء عينيها تتعاطى الدبلوماسيه القطريه
مع ازمتها مع جيرانها هم سيصبحون مثل
الليمونه
المعصوره الكاتب السعودي التركي الروجي
اسف في تغريده خاطب بها ولي عهد المملكه
لما وصفه بالبداء والسخافه التي يعتمدها
الاعلام السعودي والبعيده عن لغه اهل
السعوديه رغم الماخذ التي يسجلها البعض
على اعلام القاهره الا ان هذا الاعلام
بقيت لديه جراه ليهجو امريكا عندما شعر
مؤخرا بخذلان في ازمه الخليج القرموطي
امريكا بتشتغل بالشخه بقشيش واخر يخاطب
ترامب بعبارات سوقيه هي سياسه امريكا كده
دلوقتي تروح مطلعها
اه احنا الموقف ده يستقل كام 20 جنيه
اتفضل شخ الموقف ده يستهل كام 10 جنيه
كمان اتفضل شخلل المق ده كام وصلنا لجنيه
اهو مفيش شخلله بقى اكتر من كده قاللك لا
ده ده الحاجات القليله [__] اشوفلك 200
جنيه كده ولا حاجه شكلنا على الهوا برض
اقولك بقى ايه م عرفتكش انا كده هنضحك على
بعض احنا هص على
بعض
راجت حول العالم برامج تلفزيونيه متخصصه
باصطياد وعرض اخطاء المذيعين والمشاهير
التي تظهر على الشاشات فيعيد عرضها بقالب
ساخر في لبنان مثلا لا توجد قناه تقريبا
الا وتنتج مثل هذا البرنامج فكيف يتقبل
المدعون انتقادهم والسخريه من اخطائهم
وليد دمياطي نجم كره السله في الشرق
الاوسط تحول الى التعليق التلفزيوني
الرياضي ليرتكب سلسله لا تنتهي من الاخطاء
المهضومه وهو يقر بان برامج الاخطاء
الساخره ساهمت في شهرته
كمذيع بيلعب بس وقت تلعب و تلعب بدك
تلعب مضبوط جمات الرياضه والحكمه على طول
حساسه وحكمه ورياضه كمان جمات كثير حساسه
علىطول اح
اح لك 10 على ع على روحك الرياضيه وتقبل
النقد وليد دمياطي فعلا انتم كثير سعدتم
فيها اخيرا وردتنا تغريده لمذيع التلفزيون
السعودي الذي اخطا في تسميه العاصمه
الالمانيه الزميل محمد الذيابي تغريده
وجدانيه يقول فيها لكل الشامتين والذين
سخروا مني سامحتكم احبكم جميعا ونحن نحبك
محمد برنامجنا كان من بين الذين سخ من
خطئك على طريقه البرامج الناقده الساخره
العالميه وليس ضغينه وقد ساهم في شهرتك
فالخط ليس عيبا اخطانا اكثر منك وسخر منا
اكثر ولا شك بتطلعات
المستقبليه بكل الاحوال ان لم تتقبل مزحت
محمد فهذا اعتذار مني ومن اسره البرنامج
لك على الهواء هل رقصت في عيد الحنكه
اليهودي قبل ثمانيه شو حنكه
اه قلت الحنوكه هو
حنوكا ما ياخذني يلا هل رقصت في عيد الحنك
يا الله ليك صديقي راح اقوله باسمه العربي
عيد الانوار ما راح يزبط معي
[موسيقى]
بالعبري ختاما اذا اختلف ثعلبان على طريده
فستكون من نصيب الذئب الذي يسمع ضباه
الى
اللقاء روحي ما
تطلع غير باذني
خالقها لا هي بيد عدو ولا هي بيد
حبي مهما ار
[موسيقى]
وقسم علي
اخواني شمسه
الكسل لا يمكن
[موسيقى]
تغيب